I'm Jorgette Grosso and I'm from Boonton, New Jersey,...
...and my major is a bachelor's in electronics and computer engineering technology.
There is a big stereotype that women can't do math,...
...or can't, you know, work with high-tech stuff.
But I've taken the hardest level math course that this school offers,...
...and I'm here to attest that that's not true.
In this major, basically with the computers, we do a lot of digital programming.
Without them we'll do basic circuitry design and actually building circuits.
Yep, the number of pixels that it's seeing...
...so that it will be able to judge how far away the object is.
This major is definitely a mix between theory and lab:...
...one hour of theory and three hours of lab.
That's why I liked it.
That's why I came here.
I learn a lot better doing.
My project is an autonomous color tracking robot.
Autonomous meaning that it doesn't have a remote control.
Nothing is controlling it except for itself.
Color tracking basically will follow a specific color that you choose.
...in this case I chose red.
And then robot, it's just the thing that goes along with it; it's working on its own.